in this video i'm going to teach you two
things first of all don't believe
anybody that tells you australia is a
warm place it is bloody cold in the
middle of winter hence the jacket second
of all i'm going to show you exactly how
you can model this building right here
in arcade 25. let's go
all right so welcome back to another
tutorial on arcad 25 today we'll be
replicating this image right here so
starting off with a basic template use
whatever is available to you i'm going
to start by selecting my wall tool up
the top going to my external walls and
selecting one of the wall types along
the right hand side here for the
purposes of this video i'm simply going
to click the first wall it doesn't
matter what it is slide across to a
blank part of the screen and start
drawing basically what we can see is an
elongated rectangular shape on the
ground floor with a protruding center
spine
that is basically split across two
levels so what we're going to do is
simply show our layer of walls external
press the p button to flip to the
external edge and then create a
relatively long 35 meter rectangle to
start our project i'm then going to make
it five meters deep run that back and
finish it off here so it does look like
this building here is split in more of a
v formation than just a typical
rectangle so what i'm going to do next
is select that entire building select
our axe tool up top cut that randomly
somewhere along the page it doesn't
really matter where we cut this building
it's just to actually undulate that
shape press command e to open up our
rotate tool select once select twice and
then let's rotate that
15 degrees across
next i'm going to select these two walls
that are open press command i to join
them up repeat the same step up here
then to create our protruding shape in
the middle i'm going to hold our option
or our alt button in the center here and
simply draw another rectangle regardless
of size shape or anything i'm just going
to simply draw a square and there you
have it now we have our three-sided box
to start off with if i marquee our shape
right click show as marquee double click
the scroll wheel
you'll see that we have most of our
building ready to go it's showing
plasterboard on the outside because that
is what i selected if i tap the p button
again we'll have brickwork on the bottom
similar to what is on this reference
image for us
on the reference image they're showing
stone so we can easily select all these
walls ctrl t
override our internal or our external
surface or all of them if we wish
and find some sort of stone work to
match so let's go stone02 press ok
and there you go now we have a very
similar stonework at the bottom next
we're going to come up to our project
map again not our view map just to keep
things simple in this video go to our
first floor press escape right click on
ground floor show as trace then we're
going to go back to our wall tool let's
select something different at the top
let's go 90mm stud partition and now it
looks like it is offset just a little
bit around the entire perimeter of this
building so the easiest way for me to
replicate this is to simply draw the
outside of the building that we drew
below copying it
identically along the whole perimeter of
this build then select all of our walls
click on one of the blue lines go to our
offset tool and let's offset that 500
millimeters around the entire building
next i'm going to select the ends and
i'm going to push those out two and a
half meters away so again if we select
three open ends command i it will join
those up repeating that process on the
left and right hand side we're going to
end up with a shape something similar to
this coming back to our 3d marquee we're
going to see our building is slightly
floating and that our marquee has cut
off part of our building so right click
show all
and now we see that our building is
where it needs to be we can also see
that our floors are floating in the
wrong space so if we press control or
command 7 we can see that we have 500
millimeters in our ceiling structure now
i don't think we need that in this
particular case so what i'm simply going
to do is drop this down to 2745
drop this to 300 millimeters and keep
that at three meters click ok
then i'm going to select our entire top
floor command t
i'm going to drop that 300 millimeters
so it sits on the floor itself with
entire top floor selected i'm once again
going to press command t open up our
settings change all of the walls and
materials at once and change that to a
dark timber selection so at the moment i
don't have too many options i do have
wood walnut vertical so if we click wood
walnut vertical that's very hard to say
in a quick succession we're going to see
ourselves with a dark timber look very
similar to what's going on in this
picture next i'm going to introduce
these three balconies which seem
identical along the way so coming back
to our ground floor taking our external
walls pushing them back in line whilst
copying them so if we select one of
these walls ctrl command d and then tap
the alt or option button it allows us to
copy and paste across very very quickly
then i'm going to select our three walls
on the outside they appear to only be
about five six hundred millimeters tall
so not linked total 900 millimeters 600
plus 300 on the overall bottom
and all of a sudden we're quickly
creating what we see in this picture
next i'm going to select these three
walls click command d tap that option
button again drag it up holding shift
and let go so now we have our box start
frame that we see in the picture it's
becoming more and more obvious to me
that that top floor is a lot higher than
what we have selected so command 7 again
let's change that to 3.6 which is
automatically going to move all of our
walls up and we just have to move those
walls that we messed with a second ago
up as well it looks like the return on
these sides is a little bit thicker as
well so if we come back to our floor
plan zoom into our walls and let's say
we create a 600 deep return on all sides
we're able to duplicate that across to
the other side checking it in 3d
we have our boxed out frame now i'm
going to repeat that same step on the
other two sides there we go so you guys
don't have to watch the repetitive
process over and over again what we can
also see on this image is it's quite
repetitive on the window treatment so
they're all highlight windows roughly in
the center of this build they're all
rectangular and long paired with a few
small squares in between so coming back
to our first floor plan again zooming
out a little bit selecting our window
tool and then finding the perfect square
window so window 25 will do let's call
that 2100 long and i believe it's only
about 600 millimeters tall looking at it
in 3d it is an ugly color so let's go to
our model attributes and let's change
our materials to black
and we can keep our glass as it is so if
we drop in one window somewhere
approximately here take a look in 3d we
can see it's too low first of all so
let's increase that seal height to 1600
and let's make that significantly bigger
let's make that three meters wide
because it doesn't look appropriately
scaled i'm then going to come back into
my floor plan and basically create a few
of these windows in repetitive sequence
so that we have something similar to
what we see on our image i'm not really
going to try too hard i'm just going to
duplicate the same images time and time
again the same windows time and time
again should i say so that we have
something that looks relatively close
coming back into 3d all those windows
have been put in we see a couple small
ones a couple bigger ones and one in the
background as well now what we also see
is a boxed out window frame number of
ways to create this the easiest is with
the slab tool so let's take our slab
tool let's then create a
slab that is the same width as our
window frame let's drag it out 300
millimeters so it's not 250 millimeters
thick it can only probably be about five
millimeters thick let's change all those
materials to black as well and then
press ok we can then replicate that slab
to the top of the window and create a
side profile in the same manner as which
we created the top so that's very quick
and very easy to create a window box
effect like we have in this image it
appears that the window boxes are
predominantly only on these two windows
and there seems to be a quite large
opening in that side there which i
haven't picked up before so if we simply
drag that window make that
larger to match our opening here on the
center portion we can create a much
larger window and we can also select
this window box ctrl or command g to
group it ctrl d to move it and move it
across to our window over here command e
allows us to rotate even in 3d so then
we can rotate it to our window extend
our window significantly larger so it
fits that window box now all we're
missing is the attention to detail we're
missing that glass balustrade here the
glass balustrade and the door in the
background and a few little cutouts and
windows in the lower floor as well so
coming back up to our first floor we can
go to our balustrade tool also known as
our railing tool open up the settings
and adjust our rails to suit that
balustrade
basically it is a frameless glass
balustrade so what we're going to do is
remove all of these central posts and
rails we're going to remove that top
handrail we're going to come to panels
we're going to add one brand new panel
in the middle
which is going to be glass we don't need
any of the fixings at the top so we'll
change that to zero no frame no fixings
and we're going to change our materials
to glass as well pressing ok and
introducing our rail at the back of
these properties one goes here
one goes on the left and one goes on the
right so by introducing those
balustrades you can see that the glass
is coming up just over the edge here
on the right and the center it looks
like it is significantly taller than
what we've created so if we come back
into our settings let's increase that
height to 1200 press okay we can see
that glass peaking at the top
last but not least we also want to
introduce our doors in these sections
here so if we come across to our window
tool open up our window settings type in
sliding we'll see a magnitude of sliding
doors open up so let's just select any
random sliding door for the time being
change those materials
to match our previously selected black
frame click ok and drop this window in
roughly here we do want to make this
window significantly wider than what
they have created automatically by
default and replicate that again on the
left and right and there we go now we
have those windows in the background
coming through what we're missing for
this render is the small windows down
the bottom
a quick slab to be able to create better
shadows and a roof structure as well
which we're just simply going to create
with a slab so coming back to our first
floor plan let's copy our box window
here on the left hand side by holding
alt go to our ground floor drop a random
little window down the bottom let's make
this 1200 by 1200 with a 600 sill
press ok center that roughly into the
wall and coming back up pressing ctrl or
command up arrow twice and then up arrow
twice
down to go to our bottom page we can
quickly drop and drag another one of
those windows in downstairs so now if we
move our window at the bottom
so the head heights align with each
other we can see we quickly created
those two windows that we can see in
this image next we want to come into our
ground ceiling we want to take our slab
tool and basically trace our upper floor
so right click show as trace reference
if we hold our space button in the
center it'll automatically create a slab
over that section that it's
defined automatically we can then adjust
it to suit ever so slightly coming back
into 3d to make sure that our slab has
come into the right place indeed it has
it has automatically created our slab
now if we wanted to we could simply
select that slab control command d tap
the alt or option button drag that up so
we create some sort of roof structure
just for 3d representation purposes
nothing more that is definitely not how
flat slab would work in real life now
what we can also see is a sloping
falling site which is quite easy to
replicate in arcade so let's go to our
ground floor let's select our mesh tool
and let's simply just draw
a square
around our building now what we want to
do is create some sort of meandering
driveway
so looking from this side of the image
if we're going to replicate this render
we want to take our spline tool and we
simply want to click away a few times to
create some sort of meandering driveway
down the actual page so if we do that
all the way around
we click somewhere in the center offset
that let's offset that six meters
we can then join our spline together
click our mesh tool click on one of the
edges select the subtract button hold
space click in the middle then we can
press option or alt select our mesh
again hold the space bar now if we come
back to our 3d we'll see our two meshes
that we've created let's just simply
turn on all of our layers we can see
that if we click here we've created our
grass and in the center we've created
our driveway so let's change that to
concrete any of them will do 23 light
for editing purposes and then we can
take one of these nodes on the right
hand side
adjust that elevation lift that up let's
say
1500 mil for starters
maybe a little bit more let's do it
another 1500 mil and now we can see a
sloping falling site away we can see our
pathway here we can introduce a gate
here if we wish or we can simply drag
and drop this entire project into twin
motion if you're looking for anything
architecture related including
construction checklists which are
pivotal to any architect in the field
make sure you check out
davidtomich.com.edu it is the first link
in the description that's all from me my
name is david tomic and i'll see you
next monday